So, talking about virtual resources,
there's a lot of talk
about virtualization.
We talked about cloud computing, and
virtualization and things like that.
Once you sort of have these
virtual resources and
implement them using whatever underlying
physical resources you have, so
there's no end to what
kinds of things you can do.
We said we had to go through this
translation, and someone, maybe it's,
but that can be done at many levels, so
I thought we'll talk a little
bit about virtualization, and
the context of the security and
protection is our main interest here.
So we're not talking about
virtualization for the sake of
virtualization, but how does this
concept actually relate to isolation and
relate to protection of resources and
securing them against unauthorized
access and things like that?
So, main motivation for
virtualization comes from the fact that
operating system is large and complex.
And the different operating systems,
different applications may require
different underlying operating systems.
So one use of virtualization
commercially is actually to not be
limited to just one operating system and
be able to run multiple
operating systems.
But as I said before we going to look at
value of this idea when it comes
to protection and security.
So, remember one other thing when
you have a single operating system
supporting all of your applications
is that if the operating system is
compromised, then it's going
to impact all applications.
Every application that you have running
in that system is going to be affected
by this compromise of
the operating system because
they all have this one underlying
common operating system.
Our picture was,
we have all our apps, then we have our
operating system and the hardware.
If something goes wrong here,
of course, all of this is affected.